on the mound for the padres is you
darvish 34 year old makes the amount
tonight a second start as a padres
fourth in his career against the giants
last time out two home runs on a cut
fastball and a four seamer and a swing
and a miss strikes out darvish with a
good start
he runs it down his throw he's going to
be just in time and nice play by hasbro
he had to pick that ball out of the
jersey
of dickerson running right in front of
him and a nice play there by caratini
and hosmer second strikeout for darvish
two down and sanchez on the mound for
the giants you know kind of happy for
this kid because the first time he's
been out there since september of 2019
had some shoulder issues last year did
not pitch the whole season and a
grounder up the middle into center field
first base runner to reach on the night
for the padres a single for tommy fans
sanchez holds now he throws
and the current ball struck him out
swinging snapped off a beauty
here's crawford
crawford hits a high fly ball to right
myers back
out of here
and the giants take a one-nothing lead
as crawford hits his first of the year
and one of the few fastballs that we've
seen tonight from darvish and
crawford just unloaded on it
swinging a miss and striking out as
slater fifth strikeout for you darvish
swing and a miss back-to-back case
and then it's six strikeouts for darvish
bare-handed knocked down by sanchez has
no play cornerworth will reach
the bare hand out able to knock it down
but cronenberg too much speed aboard
with one down
on the ground and through into left
field
konaworth will take second base on the
single by machado and it's first and
second now two down
[Music]
two one two down eric hosmer coming up
up the middle into center field a base
hit here comes quarter worth around from
second he will score on the third goes
machado and this game is tied at one
eric osmer driving in the run machado at
third hosmer at first one to one the
score the pitch
and a change-up strikes him out swinging
the inning is over dwayne kuiper will be
along for the middle innings flores belt
and longoria do up for the giants in the
fourth it's one to one
[Music]
high drive deep left field pro far over
towards the dirt of the track we'll make
the catch
where he started where he ended up two
completely different places
i am not sure what happened or what he
saw in the beginning but he recovered
somehow and makes the catch turks and
profar
and a results-based business getting the
job done
there's the flash look you know he
covered a lot of ground i thought that
ball was going to be straight on towards
you know towards the wall i thought the
ball even had a chance to get out of
here but what a great job you darvish
loves it
swinging a mess and darvish picks up his
seventh strikeout
and that is a base hit to left center
profar picks it up posey will
stop at first base
chop to first on the backhand hosmer
it's a fair ball
tag in the second they did
this play by hosmer
kind of picked it before it went foul
yeah
and i can hear the guys on the infield
after hosberg loves this one steps on
the back tag tag tag forces off at
second base
right center field
will myers
the big turn at first by
austin slater he'll hold on
so he gets the hit
the giants third hit
of the game
the pitch
he got him
on a high fastball and that'll end the
inning four strikeouts for sanchez
aaron sanchez was the play of the day
and he pitched beautifully with three
strikeouts in five innings he got the
ground ball in a first and third one out
situation
and uh again really utilized all of his
pitches the fastball the curveball will
change up all working for him he winds
up going
five innings allowing six hits three of
which were infield hits one run no walks
and three strikeouts nice debut
tied at one in the seventh inning
carratini batting left-handed swings at
the first pitch hits it in the air deep
down the right field line towards the
pole gonna go
a two-run homer for victor caratini just
call him clutch padres with their first
lead of the night 3-1 welcome to san
diego victor caratini
[Music]
aboard with one away gets his first
major league hit
baseball finds its way over to the
padres dugout
[Applause]
pulled the old switcheroo on him
a little slider from peralta he takes it
that way congratulations
yeah he's fired up there it is
plants it in trying to finish off the
giants tonight
well with the saves that he's gotten so
far with the san diego padres career
stays now 207 for the right-hander
swing and a miss this time and he
strikes out for the first out of the
ninth inning
ring the bell prior
on the ground left side it's hassan kim
and his throw is in time two down in the
ninth
two down as wilmer flores stands in
padres pitchers have retired the last 12
giants in a row
combination of keller pagan and malinson
[Applause]
on the ground to third base machado to
first and the padres win
a one two three ninth inning for mark
milano picks up his third save
as the padres take the middle game of
this three-game series against the
giants and victor carratini
it's a big home run the two-run shot
an incredibly well-pitched game all the
way around for the padres and it started
with you darvish's sixth inning effort
as san diego goes on to win this one
three to one